und wir schauen mal auf die nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt der geht ist um eine
Bevölkerungsgruppe zu denen
wahrscheinlich die meisten unserer
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer nicht
zählen es geht um Milliardäre und
Multimillionäre die Linksfraktion möchte
eine einmalige Vermögensabgabe für
Multimillionäre und
Milliardäre einführen sie begründet das
unter anderem damit dass sie sagt die
reichsten 1% Vereinen fast ein Drittel
des deutschen Nettovermögens und damit
zieht sie sich auf den Artikel 106 des
Grundgesetzes Absatz 1 Nr 5 wird dort
nämlich gesagt dass dem Bund zusteht
eine einmalige Vermögensabgabe zu
erheben und darauf stütze ich hier nun
die Linksfraktion der Club der
Millionäre ist in Deutschland zum
Schluss im letzten Jahr auch noch einmal
gewachsen 1,68
Menschen haben mindestens eine Million
Dollar zur Verfügung Christian Görke
spricht nun zu diesem Thema für die
linksfunktion sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der cdu/csu der ehemalige
Bundeskanzler Konrad Adenauer wird ja in
einer Veröffentlichung der
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung zum Thema
Vermögensabgabe als Befürworter einer
energischen Lösung beschrieben um den
damaligen Wiederaufbau Westdeutschland
zu finanzieren und damit natürlich auch
die Folgen von Krieg und Zerstörung zu
überwinden und nicht nur das er war
einer der Väter der im Bundestag mit der
Aufnahme der Vermögensabgabe im
Grundgesetz nach Artikel 106 ein
Finanzinstrument uns in die Hand gegeben
hat um zukünftige
krisenbewältigen zu können insofern ist
die im Grundgesetz verankerte
Vermögensabgabe für Multimillionäre und
Milliardäre also kein linkes hirngespins
es ist deutsche Regierungspraxis und
trägt die Handschrift der CDU meine
Damen und Herren
ich muss sie nicht erklären dass wir
heute wieder angesichts dieses Krieges
dieses Angriffskrieges dieser
Energiekrise der corona-pandemie vor den
größten Krisenlasten stehen die je
dieses Land erlebt hat und das heißt die
Forderung nach einer einmaligen
Vermögensabgabe ist nicht nur legitim
sie ist auch finanzpolitisch notwendig
und das muss man sich auch noch mal auf
der Zunge zergehen lassen in diesem
Haushaltsjahr wären zur Krisenbekämpfung
sage und schreibe
440 Milliarden Euro Schulden aufgenommen
und unseren Enkeln ins obliga gelegt
aber eine Gegenfinanzierung zum Beispiel
durch eine gerechte Besteuerung der
Krisengewinner oder der Superreichen
darauf wird verzichtet und das Dew meine
Damen und Herren hat für meine Fraktion
schon mal berechnet wenn man nur die
reichsten die reichsten 0,7 Prozent bei
einer Vermögensabgabe heranzieht dann
kommt man auf Einnahmen von 310
Milliarden Euro für diesen bundesweit
also worüber reden wir wenn wir übrigens
mal über das Thema Superreiche reden
damit wir das mal ein bisschen präsenter
machen so besaß in Deutschland letztes
Jahr zwei Familien mehr Vermögen als sie
untere Hälfte der Bevölkerung also zwei
Familien mehr als 41 Millionen Menschen
ich wiederhole das nochmal für die
Bodyguards der Superreichen hier von FDP
CDU aber auch bei der FDP zwei Familien
besaßen mehr Vermögen als sie untere
Hälfte dieser Bevölkerung und das ist
doch bizarr meine Damen und Herren und
das ist auch kein Zufall denn seit
Jahren wird ja hier auch eine Politik
für die Superreichen gemacht und das
sieht man ja auch im Koalitionsvertrag
der Ampel dort wird ja jede Umverteilung
von vornherein ausgeschlossen und das
muss man sich mal vorstellen während
hier alles auf den Kopf gestellt wird
alles auf den Prüfstand steht
veränderbar verschiebbar ist ist der
Schutz der Superreichen hier in
steinenmeister das muss man sich mal
vorstellen und selbst ist dann nur noch
der Bundesfinanzminister
gebetsmühlenartig ja dahinter
zurückzieht das ist doch eigentlich der
Skandal des Tages
und deshalb habe ich mich gefreut dass
auch die SPD-Chefin die SPD-Fraktion
ihre Chefin als Partei ist das hier ist
auch die Grünen
Kollege Goerke ich habe die Uhr
angehalten gestatten Sie eine Bemerkung
oder Frage aus der afd-fraktion
und deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der SPD habe ich gefreut
dass ihre SPD-Chefin aber auch ihre
ex-grünen Chefin
Frau göreneckert endlich unsere
Forderung nach einer einmaligen
Vermögensabgabe unterstützt das haben
sie auch wie ein Partei glaube ich sogar
beschlossen aber ich finde
pressestatements und Gast
Presseartikel und Gastartikel in der
Berliner Medien Babbel reichen in dieser
Zeit nicht aus wenn Sie den Postboten
den Pflegekräften den malochen draußen
beweisen wollen das ist ernst meinen mit
dieser Gerechtigkeit dann müssen Sie
unserem Antrag heute zustimmen und meine
Damen und Herren von der cdu/csu sie
wollen doch nicht wirklich hinter Konrad
Adenauer zurücktreten oder vielen Dank
Christian Görke war das für die
Linksfraktion der er ist ja auch der
ehemalige Finanzminister des Landes
Brandenburg gewesen hat hier die Debatte
eröffnet zum Antrag der Linksfraktion
einer Vermögensabgabe für Milliardäre
und Multi Millionäre dem klyssendorf aus
der SPD-Fraktion antwortet
Präsidentin meine lieben Kollegen und
Kolleginnen ich habe mir vorgenommen als
ich in diesen Deutschen Bundestag
gewählt worden bin hier kein Quatsch zu
erzählen und mich immer an das zu halten
was ich auch sonst vertrete und
dementsprechend fällt es mir besonders
schwer heute zu diesem Antrag zu
sprechen weil es eine Forderung ist die
ich inhaltlich eigentlich auch vom Kern
her sehr unterstützenswert finde und die
auch nicht nur meine Partei und auch die
Grüne Partei jetzt in unterschiedlichen
Beschlusslagen auch als offizielle
beschlusslang der Partei herbeigeführt
haben sondern die auch glaube ich
inhaltlich komplett richtig ist deswegen
Respekt vor diesem Antrag wir haben
gerade am Wochenende auf dem
bundeskonvent der SPD dazu eine
Beschlussfassung herbeigeführt deswegen
ist es besonders geschickt diesen auch
in dieser Woche zu stellen weil sie
genau wissen dass wir ihn ablehnen
werden und zwar nicht weil wir ihn
ablehnen weil er von ihnen kommt sondern
man muss auch politisch Realitäten
anerkennen und wir haben in diesem Haus
momentan eine Koalition die sich nicht
darauf einigen konnte im
finanzpolitischen Segment in dem Bereich
aktiv zu werden
da klatschen meine guten Freunde von der
FDP das auch genau richtig so es ist so
und das muss man einfach der
Öffentlichkeit noch mal erklären es
sieht vielleicht komisch aus dass wir
inhaltliche Forderungen nicht zustimmen
die wir eigentlich gut finden aber wir
haben eine Koalition wir haben uns da
drin vereinbart man kann ein Land nicht
auf Zuruf regieren man muss nicht
gegenseitig das Vertrauen versichern man
muss sich gegenseitig Abstimmung
versichern die FDP stimmt bei unserem
Bürgergeld mit zu die FDP stimmt bei
unserer mindestlohnerhöhung zu die FDP
stimmt bei unserer wohngeld-erweiterung
zu dass es viel abverlangt das heißt im
Gegenzug müssen wir auch unsere
Versprechen einhalten dass wir
finanzpolitisch auch auf das und
fokussieren was im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart ist und da gibt es eine Menge
zu tun was wir noch gemeinsam Vorhaben
dennoch möchte ich noch mal
unterstreichen warum dieses Thema
besonders wichtig ist und ich würde mich
auch freuen wenn Sie vielleicht ihre
Russland Avancen und so manche
außenpolitische Äußerungen gelassen
könnten weil dann könnten wir vielleicht
auch irgendwann wirklich zu politischen
Mehrheiten kommen in diesem Parlament
und nicht nur zu gesellschaftlichen
Mehrheiten die es für dieses Thema gibt
weil dann würde es möglicherweise auch
eine politische mehr dafür geben die
Ungleichheit der Vermögen in diesem Land
ist so hoch wie noch nie es gibt einen
Wert der besonders interessant ist dass
der sogenannte die Gini Koeffizient der
geht von 0 bis 1 bei 0 nimmt er an dass
alle Menschen in diesem Land das gleiche
Vermögen haben bei eins hat einer alles
in Deutschland haben wir ein
Gini-Koeffizient momentan von 0,82 das
ist ein extrem hoher Wert das ist nicht
nur ein extrem hoher Wertes der
dritthöchste Wert von allen OECD-Staaten
wir sind dabei weit über den Werten zum
Beispiel von Frankreich Belgien anderen
Ländern die haben alle um die 0,6 das
kann man sich auch alles noch mal
nachlesen und das hat Gründe das hat
nämlich den Grund dass wir in
Deutschland Vermögen und Erbschaften so
gut wie gar nicht der Anteil der
substanzsteuer in unserem
Gesamtsteueraufkommen ist bei zwei
Prozent der OECD-Durchschnitt ist bei 5
ein Land wie Frankreich hat knapp zehn
Prozent Anteil der vermögensbezogenen
Steuern sogar Großbritannien hat 13%
ihres gesamtsteueraufkommens ist
vermögensbezogen das heißt wir haben
hier einen ordentlichen Weg den wir noch
gemeinsam gehen müssen weil wir dringend
den Bedarf haben hier die Ungleichheit
abzubauen die großen Vermögen
abzuschöpfen und dafür mehr
Gerechtigkeit in unserer Gesellschaft zu
sorgen und dafür
und dafür wird sich auch die
Sozialdemokratie einsetzen denn eben hat
der Görke das ja schon erwähnt wir haben
große Herausforderungen zu finanzieren
die größten Krisen überhaupt wenn man
sich anguckt welche entlastungspakete
wir geschnürt haben wir können uns nicht
darauf einigen wie wir die Einnahmen
stärken wir haben jetzt ein Gutachten
vom Sachverständigenrat der
Bundesregierung vorliegen wo einen
Ansatz drin ist aber wir gehen immer
noch nicht an das ran was wirklich
nämlich Geld bringen würde und das sind
die Vermögen der Millionäre und der
Milliardäre und das wäre geeignet um
unsere Krisen zu finanzieren
deshalb vielleicht als letztes Wort noch
dazu wir meine Fraktion jetzt in der
neuen Beschlusslage meine Partei die
Grüne Partei meine parlamentarische
linke die dazu im Sommer ein Gutachten
geschrieben hat wir werden uns weiterhin
dafür einsetzen und da gucke ich gerade
in Richtung der FDP dass wir
gesellschaftliche Mehrheiten und am Ende
auch politische Mehrheiten für dieses
Thema bekommen denn ich bin ganz fest
davon überzeugt dass wenn man sich
dieser Frage nicht widmet und sich den
Argumenten verschließt dann gefährdet
man sich dann gefährdet man den sozialen
Zusammenhalt in unserem Land nachhaltig
und das dürfen wir nicht riskieren
deswegen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit wir müssen den Antrag
leider abgeben
tim klissendorf hat hier schon einmal
erläutert warum seiner Fraktion in
diesem Antrag nicht zustimmen wird es
muss noch darüber entschieden werden ob
dieser Antrag an die entsprechenden
Ausschüsse weitergereicht wird oder
direkt nach der Debatte abgestimmt wird
nächste Redner ist Christian Freiherr
von Städten
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegen Kollegen bei der Linkspartei
ist es so wie bei täglich grüßt das
Murmeltier jedes Jahr suchen Sie sich
einen anderen Anlass um hier im
Deutschen Bundestag entweder ein
Gesetzentwurf oder ein Antrag zur
Einführung der Vermögenssteuer oder
einer Vermögensabgabe hier vorzulegen
allein in den letzten zehn Jahren war
dies 20 mal gefallen
aber dieses Mal Herr Bartsch dieses Mal
muss man sagen so schlampig
und so wenig in die Tiefe gehen wie
dieses Mal haben sie noch nie gearbeitet
in ihrem gesamten Antrag der auf eine
Seite passt steht keine einzige Zahl
drin kein Steuersatz den den Sie sich
vorstellen keinen Freibetrag für
Familien oder für Mittelstand in sich
vorstellen noch nicht einmal ein Datum
wann es beginnen soll und auch keine
Definition für wen dieses Gesetz
überhaupt gelten soll sie schreiben in
dem Antrag nun eine gelöst von
Multimillionären ich habe da mal im
Duden nachgeblättert was ist ein
Multimillionär ein Multimillionär ist
nach Definition
jemand der ein Vermögen von mehr als
zwei Millionen Euro auf dem Papier
besitzt inklusive Haus
Altersversorgung und allem was dazu
gehört also nicht Barvermögen auf dem
Konto sondern alles was er hat und da
ist bei meinem Familienhaus in München
oder in Stuttgart oder in Köln obwohl es
sehr klein ist ein sehr kleines
Einkommen oder Rente vorher doch schon
ein relativ hohes Vermögen angehört ja
nehmen Sie den Bäckermeister mein
Wahlkreis Schwäbisch Hall Bäckermeister
zwei Familien ein Auto mit dem man die
Brötchen ausfährt der ist bei 2
Millionen dabei dieser Bäckermeister der
jetzt den letzten zwei Jahren in der
corona-zeit leiden musste der jetzt
doppelt so hohe Strompreise und Ölpreise
zahlen muss der in dritter Generation
arbeitet mit der Familie überlegt ob er
überhaupt weitermachen kann den wollen
Sie jetzt noch einmal zusätzlich durch
eine mittelstandsvermögensabgabe den
Todesstoß setzen das ist nicht der
Umgang den wir mit dem Mittelstandes
nein ich habe auch
nach nochmaligem Lesen keine einzige
Zahl in dem Antrag gefunden was ich dort
finde ist eine Aufforderung an uns
okay das stimmt dann ist es eine aus
dann ist es eine aus das ist
Aufforderung an die Bundesregierung und
an den Finanzminister einmal bei der
anderen Parteien den Grünen und der SPD
nachzuschauen was die in den letzten
Jahren doch für Vorstellungen hat aber
billiger und peinlicher geht's da
wirklich nicht und bei allem Respekt der
Kollege Düsseldorf hat sich ja hier
heute etwas zurückgehalten ja allerdings
vor drei Monaten im NTV Interview ist
oder etwas deutlicher geworden na klar
gesagt was die Ziele sind nach einem
Freibetrag will man zehn bis 30 Prozent
teilenteignung durchsetzen wenn man in
Zukunft die Mehrheiten hat und was ich
hier gehört habe was ich hier gehört
habe war das ja schon fast eine
Koalitionsaussage zum Gunsten der linken
und ich glaube sie hätten das ruhig
etwas näher formulieren können wenn man
allerdings bei den Linken nachschaut was
die in den letzten Jahren ihren
deutschen Bundestag eingebracht haben
zum Thema Vermögensabgabe und Vermögen
Steuer dann ist es etwas schwieriger
eine einheitliche Linie zu finden wenn
ich
schauen ins Jahr 2018 wo wir uns über
eine Vermögen Steuer die ja jährlich
erhoben werden soll was ihr Vorschlag da
ist da stehen einem schon die Haare zu
Berge sie wollen eine jährliche Abgabe
wollten sie von fünf Prozent auf den
Verkehrswert jährlich 5% der
Fraktionsvorsitzender auf den das heißt
im ersten Jahr ist Wohnzimmer Weg im
zweiten ist es Bad Bett und dritten die
Diele im 10 Jahr muss die Vermieter der
Garage fahren nach 20 Jahren ist das
Haus komplett weggesteuert das ist die
Vermögenssteuer jährlich und jetzt
können wir zu Ihrem Vorschlag der
Vermögensabgabe im letzten Jahr fast der
gleiche Titel zu dem Thema allerdings
etwas konzentrierter und ein Kollege sie
haben 300 Milliarden Euro vorher genannt
als mögliche Einnahmeposten den eine
Vermögensabgabe wie sie sich vorstellen
bringen kann in dem Antrag letztes Jahr
sind sie etwas genauer geworden wie sie
die 3 Milliarden Euro einnehmen wollen
halben sie im Antrag aus dem letzten
Jahr dass sie nämlich nicht nur die
Menschen die hier direkt steuerpflichtig
sind heranziehen wollen sie der
einmaligen Vermögensabgabe sondern sie
wollen auch alle Menschen einbeziehen
die beschränkt steuerpflichtig sind also
Menschen die nicht in Deutschland leben
die keine deutsche sind aber die
Vermögen in Deutschland haben den wollen
sie 100.000 Euro Freibetrag geben und
den Rest zwischen 10 und 30 Prozent
bestören ich frag mich wie sie auf die
300 Milliarden kommen wollen also nehmen
sie den Chinesen den Herrli bekannt als
ein vermögender Unternehmer der zehn
Prozent an der Daimler AG hält
dem wollen sie 100.000 Euro Freibetrag
geben und dann wollen sie mit 30%
besteuern na herzlichen Glückwunsch und
viel Erfolg wollte Stuttgarter Finanzamt
demnach China einen Steuerbescheid
schicken oder was soll er damit machen
oder gehen sie nach Brandenburg wo alle
Mast eine Fabrik baut mit 40.000
Mitarbeiter wo am Ende des Tages der
Staat Zuschüsse zahlt und auf der
anderen Seite wollen sie den besteuern
um auf ihre drei sich 300 Milliarden
Euro zu kommen das ist am Ende des Tages
nicht durchdacht und deswegen meine
Damen und normalerweise wenn wir hier
Finanzgesetz oder Anträge beraten
formuliere ich das auch so dass die
Debatte festgestellt hat dass wir
unterschiedliche Ansichten haben und ich
mich auf die Beratungen Finanzausschuss
freuen werde allerdings ist es heute
kann es gar nicht der Fall sein weil in
ihrem Antrag ja gar nichts drin steht
was wir beraten können und deswegen ist
auch erfolgreich dass diese Antrag nicht
den Finanzausschuss überwiesen wird
sondern wir heute direkt darüber
abstimmen und ihn auch ablehnen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Christian von Städten
zumindest für die cdu/csu-fraktion und
jetzt hören wir mal
Umfeld da wir jetzt endezeit 4:29 Uhr
morgen früh haben kommen erst mal
freundliche Kapelle und der Hinweis
darauf dass ich diesmal etwas genauer
als sonst auf die Redezeiten achten
werde
nein bei ihm noch nicht Frau weg also
ich habe gerade meine meine
Sitzungsleitung Wolfgang Kubicki der
Bundestagsvizepräsident wird jetzt
verschärft wir angekündigt hat auf die
Redezeiten achten oder schauen wir mal
Katharina Beck jetzt am Rednerpult für
die Grünen Bürgerinnen und Bürger dank
des Antrags der Linken setzt sich der
Deutsche Bundestag heute mit einem sehr
wichtigen Thema auseinander der
Vermögensverteilung in unserem Land ich
möchte gerne ein paar Fakten in die
Diskussion bringen
Deutschland ist im globalen und auch im
europäischen Vergleich ein
wirtschaftlich starkes und wohlhabendes
Land und ich bin stolz darauf dass wir
in vielen Bereichen zum Beispiel der
technologievorreiter sind doch worauf
ich wirklich nicht stolz bin ist dass
wir auch in der vermögensungleichheit
ganz vorne mit dabei sind und dass wir
innerhalb aller europäischen OECD-Länder
die zweithöchste Ungleichheit bei
Vermögen haben wie ungleich das Vermögen
in Deutschland verteilt ist zeigen die
Daten des sozioökonomischen Panels ganz
objektiv das Vermögens der 1% der
Menschen besitzt etwa 35% des
Gesamtvermögens und damit sogar etwas
mehr als 90 Prozent der restlichen
Menschen in unserem Land die Statistik
fokussiert auf die ca 63 Millionen über
18-Jährigen im Land in absoluten Zahlen
haben
650.000 sehr vermögende Erwachsene in
Deutschland mehr Vermögen als 55
Millionen erwachsene Menschen zusammen
und wie gesagt sind da die Kinder und
Jugendlichen noch nicht mit eingerechnet
diese starke Konzentration bei wenigen
ist unter den obersten 0,1% sogar noch
höher
ungefähr vier von zehn Menschen in
Deutschland haben sogar einfach gar
keine Rücklagen um dieser Krise und den
krassen Preissteigerungen finanziell
begegnen zu können und hinter den
abstrakten Zahlen verbergen sich ganz
persönliche Schicksale in meiner
Heimatstadt Hamburg hat zum Beispiel
fast jede zweite Mieter in gerade Angst
vor dem Verlust ihrer Wohnung weil sie
Preise so stark ansteigen und sie keine
Rücklagen hat und leider ist diese
Entwicklung die sich in den letzten
Jahren sogar deutlich verstärkt hat
folgendermaßen zu beobachten zwischen 93
und 2018 ist das Vermögen der Top 1
Prozent um das 12-fache gegenüber den
nahezu 0 Anteil der unteren 50%
angestiegen da ist die Situation
weitgehend stagniert
es muss uns besorgen die Schere zwischen
Arm und Reich klappt weiter auseinander
das ist leider Fakt und das Versprechen
unserer sozialen Marktwirtschaft ist
aber Teilhabe am Wohlstand und das ist
leider in dieser Situation dann eine
Erosion dieses Versprechens und deswegen
ist das so ein wichtiges Thema wir
reflektieren hier das Thema
Gerechtigkeit was ist da das Ziel klar
ist hundert Prozent materielle
Gleichheit können und wollen wir nicht
erreichen aber Vermögen einfacher gesagt
Geld ist nun mal ein Mittel zur
Erfüllung von Bedürfnissen und im
Endeffekt Freiheit und Teilhabe
Möglichkeiten das sollte fair verteilt
sein das kann ein Bedürfnis nach warmer
Wohnung oder vollem kühlschranken
Grundbedürfnis genauso stehen wie aber
auch das möchte ich in so einem
wohlhabenland dem Wunsch nach einem
schicken Kleidungsstück oder einem
schönen Familienurlaub auch mal am
Mittelmeer viele können sich das nicht
mehr leisten selbst das Zelten nicht an
der Nordsee ist es also gerecht dass ein
großer Teil der Menschen in unserem Land
diese und andere Freiheiten nicht
wahrnehmen können wenn beim winzigen
Teil der Reichtum im Überfluss vorhanden
ist ich sehe das nicht so
aber neben der Frage nach Gerechtigkeit
für eine Ungleichheit hätte gleiche
Vermögensverteilung zu konkreten
negativen Konsequenzen die auch Studien
belegen höherer Drogenkonsum höhere
Kriminalitätsrate schlechtere Bildung
mehr psychische Erkrankungen um nur ein
paar Aspekte aufzuzählen und gerade im
Hinblick auf unsere freiheitliche
Demokratie die vom aktiven Zusammenhalt
lebt ist die Ungleichheit ein großes
Problem sie ist vermutlich mit ein
großer Grund für sinkendes Vertrauen in
unser System
wichtig ist in der gesamten Debatte eine
Unterscheidung Vermögen und Einkommen
viele verwechseln das anders als bei den
eben genannten vermögenszahlen ist das
Bild bei den Einkommen etwas
ausgeglichener allerdings driftet auch
hier über Zeit die Entwicklung
auseinander und deswegen ist auch da die
Entwicklung leider mit ein Teil für die
vertrauenserosion was jetzt ganz
spannend ist Einkommen und Vermögen
hängen zusammen denn wer viel hat
profitiert auch von Einkünften Einkommen
aus Vermögen die Immobilien besitzt oder
Aktien oder Betriebsvermögens besitzt
und deswegen mussten wir den Soli
anpassen weil dort die Einkommen so
stark über den Löhnen hinaus gestiegen
waren nämlich aus Einkünften aus
vermögensbezogenen Werten und der
Handlungsdruck ist real
ich bin auch in diesem Zusammenhang
offen für die Vorschläge der
Wirtschaftsweisen vielen Dank an dieser
Stelle für ihre harte Arbeit den
Spitzensteuersatz zu erhöhen oder ein
energiesoli für besonders gut
verdienende Menschen einzuführen um für
mehr Gerechtigkeit und Zielgenauigkeit
bei den Entlastungsmaßnahmen zu sorgen
aber
fakt ist es gibt in dieser Koalition für
das Instrument einer Vermögensabgabe
keine Übereinstimmung nichtsdesto
weniger ist mir wichtig dass wir auch in
der Ampel die Debatte um die von mir
gerade vorgetragenen Fakten zur
vermögensungleichheit und
Einkommensentwicklung in unserem Land
aus der tabu-ecke in eine
gestaltungsecke bringen die Gefahren für
unsere Demokratie sind nämlich real und
ich möchte hier gemeinsam Weiterkommen
vielen dank
vielen Dank Katharina beck war dass die
finanzpolitische Sprecherin der Grünen
ja sie hat auch noch mal daran erinnert
dass ja die Wirtschaftsweisen sich
gerade ausgesprochen hatten für eine
bestärkere Besteuerung zumindest von gut
verdienen was bei Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner nicht gerade auf
Zustimmung gestoßen ist Albrecht Glaser
jetzt für die afd-fraktion
wie kann man der Zivilgesellschaft
zusätzliches Geld entziehen um damit
noch mehr Staat zu finanzieren
knapp 900 Milliarden an Steuern nimmt
der Staat dieses Jahr ein knapp 380
davon der Bund das sind über sechs
Prozent mehr als im Feuer und nur eine
Zwischenbemerkung das was wir vorliegt
als Modell hat mit Adenauers
Lastenausgleich nichts aber auch gar
nichts zu tun null
das sind gut 23 Prozent der jährlichen
Wirtschaftsleistung und zusammen mit den
Sozialabgaben mehr als 40 Prozent mit
dieser Abgabenquote liegt Deutschland an
der Spitze der großen OECD-Länder die
Linke meint der Staat müssen zusätzlich
direkt auf Vermögenswerte deren Erträge
bereits der Einkommensteuer unterliegen
zugreifen
man hat immerhin erkannt dass ein
solcher Zugriff etwa auf die Substanz
von Unternehmen dazu führen könnte das
Zitat
liquiditäts- und Finanzierungsprobleme
beim Immobilien oder
Unternehmensvermögen entstehen können
Zitat Ende um die Vermögensabgabe
dennoch zu leisten Zitat könne man es
den Abgabepflichtigen ermöglichen ihre
abgabebelastung in dauerhafte
Staatsbeteiligung umzuwandeln Zitat Ende
das ist das was das Land braucht mehr
Staatsbeteiligung an
Wirtschaftsunternehmen
erinnern uns an die NordLB wir erinnern
uns an die WestLB an die IKB eine von
der KfW beherrschte Tochter die als
erste in der Finanzkrise zusammenbrach
alle Institute
vollgesogen mit Politikern in den
Aufsichtsräten die dort ihre
Aufsichtspflichten so wahrgenommen haben
dass alle die Unternehmen
zusammengebrochen sind
der vermögenszugriff soll so das Konzept
für 20 Jahre jährlich etwa 20 bis 25
Milliarden staatsanwärme erbringen ein
Betrag etwa in der Höhe der eu-umlage
Deutschlands in den Jahren 14 bis 17 die
sich in 2028 auf über 50 Milliarden
verdoppeln wird eine messbare nutzen
werden unsere Bürger welche diese Mittel
aufbringen nicht daraus ziehen und
Europa auch nicht
so verhält es sich auch mit den
deutschen Leistungen für die sogenannte
Entwicklungshilfe eine Evaluation zu
diesem Kapitel des kapitalexporters hat
es noch nie in Deutschland gegeben ich
könnte dazu sehr vertiefstes erzählen
2020 hat der Bund fast 30 Milliarden in
der Welt verteilt mehr als die EU deren
Leistung zu 25% zusätzlich von
Deutschland finanziert werden somit
zahlen wir Deutschland genauso viel wie
die USA die mehr als die vierfache
Wirtschaftskraft hat als wir die
ehrlichen Kosten der ungesteuerten
Migration die jährlichen durften
gesamtstaatlich bei 50 Milliarden liegen
man könnte die auch vermeiden alle
könnte man sich vermeiden
4 Minuten reichen leider nicht aus diese
Liste zu vervollständigen das könnte
noch ein langer Nachmittag werden
Verantwortung meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren trägt für all dies niemand es
gibt keine politische Verantwortung
Deutschland hat kein Einnahmeproblem es
hat jede Menge ausgabeprobleme diese
sind vor allem politischer Natur gute
Staatsführung muss man lernen und man
braucht ein amtsethos das ist das
Gegenteil von allfälligem Stimmenkauf
mit viel Geld um die nächste Wahl zu
gewinnen
die AFD hat die Bundesregierung im März
gefragt wie sie es mit der
Vermögensabgabe halten ich zitiere aus
der Antwort Zitat der von den
Regierungsparteien getragene
Koalitionsvertrag enthält wieder eine
Vereinbarung zur Einführung einer
Vermögensabgabe noch zur Wiederbelebung
der Vermögenssteuer noch zu Einführung
eines Lastenausgleichs etwaige Fragen
diesbezüglich stellen damit
hypothetische Erwägungen da solche haben
wir heute hier angestellt hoffentlich
bleibt es dabei herzlichen Dank vielen
Dank Herr Kollege
als nächster das Wort der Kollege
Maximilian Mordhorst FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
glücklicherweise kann ich mich darüber
freuen dass diese Ampel eine
unmissverständliche Aussage im
Koalitionsvertrag im sondierungspapier
zu all diesen Themen getroffen hat ich
möchte sie gerne zitieren wir werden in
Deutschland keine
substanzsteuern einführen und wir werden
keine Steuern in Deutschland erhöhen das
ist das richtige Signal dass wir senden
das ist das Signal finanzpolitischer
Verlässlichkeit das besonders in diesen
Zeiten der Energiekrise der
wirtschaftlichen Gefahren vor denen
unser Land steht extrem wichtig ist wir
müssen nämlich Investitionsanreize
setzen und das tun wir nicht indem wir
mit einer Vermögenssteuer mit einer
Vermögensabgabe was auch immer für
rechts und Sicherheit sorgen und indem
wir noch geringere Anreize setzen hier
zu investieren wir müssen mehr Anreize
setzen dass Menschen wieder Lust haben
hier zu arbeiten hier zu investieren das
ist der Auftrag den wir gemeinsam haben
und deswegen müssen wir jedem
Arbeitnehmer aber genauso auch
Unternehmer jedem selbstständigen
dankbar sein der auch in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten seine wirtschaftliche
Zukunft in Deutschland sieht und hier
investiert
der Teufel steckt nämlich wie immer im
Detail wenn man über Vermögensabgabe
Vermögens Steuern diskutiert und dieses
Detail umgehen sie ja bewusst in ihrem
Antrag es wurde eben schon darauf
hingewiesen ihre Anträge werden im
detaillierter weil sie selbst merken wo
liegt das eigentliche Problem bei diesen
substanzsteuern dass man auch bei der
Erbschaftssteuer sieht bei der
Grundsteuer sieht die genaue Definition
von Vermögen ist schwierig sie tun in
ihren Redebeiträgen immer so als wäre
Vermögen das was irgendwo auf einem
Girokonto liegt als gäbe es Menschen in
Deutschland die auf Ihrem Girokonto 25
Milliarden oder was auch immer liegen
haben aber dieses Geld das liegt im
Betriebsvermögen zu großem Teil das kann
auch mal in Immobilien liegen wenn sie
sagen multimillion fängt ab 2 Millionen
an dann wären die halben
Immobilieneigentümer die
Immobilieneigentümer von halt Berlin
bald vermögensabgabepflichtig weil eine
Gegend mal Hit geworden ist sie haben
früh investiert so geht es nicht sie
würden Menschen dazu zwingen hier zu
verkaufen sie würden Investitionen
verringern es wäre genau der falsche Weg
arbeiten Sie doch mit uns an ganz
anderen arbeiten Sie doch mit uns
gemeinsam daran dass Menschen wieder
Lust haben Vermögen aufzubauen in diesem
Land das ist nämlich das eigentliche
Problem viel zu Menschen viel zu wenige
Menschen in diesem Land entscheiden sich
für Eigentum viel zu wenige Menschen in
diesem Land investieren und das ist das
Problem wenn die Anreize nicht stimmen
erhöhen Sie doch mal mit uns gemeinsam
den Sparer Pauschbetrag das junge
Menschen oder Aufsteiger oder Arbeiter
für die sie mal stehen wollten Lust
haben in Aktien zu investieren ich
erinnere mal es gibt so etwas wie ein es
gibt so etwas wie Mitarbeiter
Kapitalbeteiligung das wollen wir
attraktiver machen ja sie rufen jetzt
rein aber die Beteiligung von Arbeitern
am produktivkapital das ist nicht meine
Idee das ist eine Idee von Karl Marx den
sie so gerne vor sich hertragen
marktwirtschafts macht's möglich setzen
sie da doch einmal Anreize dass auch die
Arbeitnehmer mehr Anteile haben an den
an den Vermögen die sie erzeugen
insofern fördern Sie mit uns Eigentum
wir werden uns dafür einsetzen dass
Leute Lust darauf haben und vielleicht
lesen sie ab und an auch mal bei ihrem
Idol Karl Marx nach sie haben ja
Adenauer so freudig zitiert ich freue
mich wenn die Marktwirtschaft bereits
das erledigt hat worüber Karl Marx
geschrieben hat wir sorgen dafür dass
auch weiterhin Eigentum gerade für
mittlere und kleine Einkommen in
Deutschland attraktiv wird wir wollen es
gemeinsam machen ich freue mich darauf
vielen Dank
Maximilian Motors war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und nächste Rednerin hier
in der Aussprache zu dem Antrag der
Linksfraktion wird sein die Abgeordnete
Frauke Heiligenstadt für die
Sozialdemokraten sie sitzt im
Finanzausschuss
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir haben schwierige Zeiten in
Deutschland die Inflation steigt
exorbitant die Lebensmittel und
Energiepreise sind massiv angestiegen
aus diesem Grund haben die
Bundesregierung und dieser Bundestag
bisher insgesamt drei entlastungspakete
auf den Weg gebracht die in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in ihrem Umfang einmalig
sind sie umfassen insgesamt 300
Milliarden Euro damit entlasten wir die
Menschen und die Unternehmen in unserem
Land
zum Beispiel ich will eine kleine
Auflistung machen mit Direktzahlung und
der energiepreispauschale von 300 Euro
mit dem Kinderbonus von 100 Euro pro
Kind oder den heizkostenzuschüssen und
270 Euro für Wohngeldbezieher und 230
Euro für Bafög-Empfänger helfen wir
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
mit Steuererleichterung und Erhöhungen
des Grundfreibetrages bei der
Einkommensteuer vermindern wir die
Steuerabgaben für Steuerpflichtige
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer mit
Rentenerhöhung in lange nicht da
gewesenem Ausmaß für dieses Jahr und
auch voraussichtlich für das kommende
Jahr unterstützen wir die Menschen die
lange Zeit unser Land aufgebaut haben
und jetzt in ihrem wohlverstandenen
wohlverdienten Ruhestand sind mit neuen
innovativen verkehrstickets wie dem
deutschlandticket ermöglichen wir mit
den Ländern gemeinsam eine völlig neue
Nutzung des öffentlichen
personalverkehrs in unserer Republik und
erleichtern damit auch zugleich der
Mobilität der Menschen im gesamten Land
und
gerade erst heute morgen oder heute
Mittag haben wir mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz das
Kindergeld für unsere Familien im Land
nochmals in einer bisher nie dagewesenen
höher erhöht auf 250 Euro pro Kind für
Studierenden Auszubildende in diesem
Land haben wir die bafög-sätze erhöht
und die Zugangsvoraussetzungen
erleichtert und wir haben heute
ebenfalls mit der Einführung des
Bürgergeldes eine umfangreiche Reform
unserer Sozialgesetzgebung auf den Weg
gebracht die insbesondere
einkommensschwächeren Menschen in
unserem Land neue Perspektiven gibt und
auch gerade eben haben wir die
wohngelderhöhung besprochen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und dass wir
den Mindestlohn für 12 Euro eingeführt
haben dass er wenig jetzt nur noch
nebenbei und ja
ja die Wirtschaftsweisen haben recht
wenn sie empfehlen die
Spitzensteuersätze anzuheben oder die
Einführung eines Energiepreis Solis zu
prüfen deshalb müssen wir uns auch mit
der solidarischen Finanzierung dieser
staatlichen Aufgaben befassen aber was
macht die Linke in diesem Haus sie holt
einen Antrag aus 2021 als es noch keine
Energiekrise gegeben hat aus der
Schublade kürzt ihn deutlich ein weil
sie gemerkt hat dass die konkreten
Vorschläge die sie vor anderthalb Jahren
gemacht haben gar nicht umzusetzen sind
und schon gar nicht schnell wirksam
werden könnten und sie bringt dann
diesen eingekürzten Antrag eben wieder
auf die Tagesordnung ich kann das ja
verstehen als Opposition macht man das
auch nur meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren mit alten Anträgen verhält es
sich leider nicht so wie mit alten
Weinen sie werden nicht besser wenn man
sie häufiger wiederholt und wenn sie
lange alt genug sind
und ja auch die SPD will dass starke
Schultern mehr tragen als schwache
Schultern und ja auch meine Partei hat
beim debattenkonvent letztes Wochenende
einen entsprechenden Beschluss gefasst
der eine einmalige Vermögensabgabe
befürwortet eine gerechte
verfassungskonforme Besteuerung von
Einkommen Vermögen Erbschaften sowie
gewinnen und Kapitalerträgen dient der
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit und die in dem
Zusammenhalt in unserem Land und in
unserer Gesellschaft und das haben wir
auch nicht erst seit zwei Wochen
deutlich gemacht sondern das ist auch in
unserem Programm enthalten das ist gar
kein Geheimnis allerdings ist ihr Antrag
Liebe linke Fraktion lediglich ein
populistischer showantrag sie machen
sich keine Mühe auch nur in irgendeiner
Form konkreter zu werden sie haben das
ja alles weggestrichen bei der Frage
nach den konkreten
Umsetzungsmöglichkeiten ja von Ihnen
vorgeschlagenen Abgabe bleiben sie
schlicht und ergreifend blank
eins ist jedenfalls klar Liebe linke
Opposition so wird das nichts mit der
Vermögensabgabe im Gegenteil die
häufiger sie das Wiederholen umso
stärker leisten sie der wichtigen Frage
eines solidarischen Finanzierung unserer
großen Aufgaben in der Krise einen
Bärendienst vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Heiligenstadt
ja Frauke Heiligenstadt für die
SPD-Fraktion hier und auch die
spd-partei hat sich am Wochenende für
eine gerechte Besteuerung von Einkommen
Vermögen Erbschaften ausgesprochen und
die Verteilungsfrage würde sich in
dieser Zeit zu dringlich wie lange nicht
mehr stellen heißt es in einem Antrag
der am Wochenende von der Partei hier
verabschiedet worden ist Sebastian Brehm
jetzt für die Union diese Antrag wurde
ja wurde erwähnt ja schon mehrfach
gestellt eigentlich jedes Jahr
lieber Kollege kackes entspricht auch
ihren Profil insofern absolut in Ordnung
aber was viel erschreckender ist ist das
heute in diesen Parlament auch die
Grünen und die SPD mit den Äußerungen
auch der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin kyrin Eckert
Saskia esken klüsendorf Frau
Heiligenstadt das bestätigt haben dass
auch die FDP und die Grünen diese
Vermögensabgabe wollen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
ich kann nur sagen dieser Antrag der
Linken wenn der umgesetzt würde durch
SPD und Grüne noch dazu
gefährden den Wohlstand für alle in
unserem Land dieser Antrag schafft
Misstrauen in Arbeit und in notwendige
Investitionen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen herzlich willkommen in der Welt
des Neides des missgunstes und der
Umverteilung von
Rot-Rot-Grün liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
unabhängig von der Frage dass das
überhaupt nicht verfassungsrechtlich
zulässig wäre das wissen sie auch darf
ich darf ich den wissenschaftlichen
Beirat beim Finanzministerium zitieren
zu diesem Thema der wissenschaftliche
Beirat hat gesagt Vertrauen darin dass
man über sein Erspartes und seine
Investitionen morgen auch noch verfügen
kann ist die Grundvoraussetzung für die
Bereitschaft zu sparen und in einem Land
zu investieren und der wissenschaftliche
Beirat sagt weiter Deutschland steht mit
den digitalen Wandel dem Klimawandel und
demografischen Wandel derzeit vor gleich
drei großen Herausforderungen deren
Bewältigung auch umfangreiche private
Investitionen erfordert
der Ruf als sichere Investitionsstandort
ist damit der Schlüssel zur Bewältigung
dieser Krisen so weit der
wissenschaftliche parat das sollten Sie
Ernst nehmen apropos Bereitschaft zum
Sparen
wir haben die höchsten Steuereinnahmen
in unserem Land
und sie schaffen es als Regierung nicht
die den Finanzen solide umzugehen wir
haben 10.000 neue Stellen in der
Regierung geschaffen zehntausend neue
Stellen in der Regierung sie haben die
meisten Staatssekretäre sie haben seit
Bestehen der Republik die Bazooka
ausgebracht und den doppelwumms und
ballern das Geld an alle raus ich mache
bloß mal einen ich mache bloß mal einen
Beispiel mit ich mache bloß ein Beispiel
mit der energiespreipauschale wir haben
gesagt geben Sie es doch denjenigen die
auch bedürftig sind sie müssen doch das
nicht jedem geben aber sie ballern das
Geld raus auf Teufel komm raus ohne
einzusparen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und ohne es zielgerichtet
einzusetzen
sie tun das was sie hier vorschlagen in
der praktischen Umsetzung keineswegs und
sie schaffen Arbeitsanreize ab liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen der FDP leider
haben sich da mitgestimmt
bürgergeldeinführung Abschaffung der
Sanktionen bei Hartz IV
im Bereich der Energie
verteuern sie künstlich die Energie weil
sie das Abschalten der Kernkraftwerke
viel zu früh zur vornehmen und sie
führen weitere bürokratische Maßnahmen
ein anstatt endlich ein
belastungsmoratorium vorzunehmen für
handwerkindustrie und Mittelstand liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Wachstum geht
anders sie müssen Anreize schaffen für
Arbeit und wir brauchen wieder ein
Lohnabstandsgebot für diejenigen die
jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen das müssen
sie tun das wäre die richtige Entlastung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich sage Ihnen
solide Mittelständler hidden champions
die in unsere Republik sind die
Eigenkapital basiert sind wenn sie jetzt
das Eigenkapital dieser Firmen und Sie
haben ja vorgeschlagen sie haben ja
vorgeschlagen 50 Prozent weil sie
richten sich ja an dem damaligen Gesetz
aus 50 Prozent Vermögen zu entnehmen
dann machen sie die Arbeitsplätze in
unserem Land kaputt mit ihrer Politik
machen sie Arbeitslosigkeit und sie
machen die Menschen
ärmer deswegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und das will ich schon auch
noch mal sagen bei dem Antrag wenn Sie
den Vergleich machen mit dem
Lastenausgleichsgesetz von 1952 dann ist
dieser Vergleich natürlich völlig falsch
damals hat man diejenigen entlastet oder
denjenigen was
verteilt sozusagen die durch Flucht und
Vertreibung aus den damals ehemaligen
Ostgebieten nach dem Krieg enteignet
worden sind und deswegen kann man den
Vergleich heute überhaupt nicht machen
das ist unseriös und findet von uns
keinerlei Zustimmung und liebe Kollegen
und Kollegen
sie übersehen eins
sie übersehen bei ihren Forderungen dass
wir aktuell schon eine massive
Vermögensabgabe haben und diese nennt
sich Inflation und anstatt und anstatt
zu entlasten und zwar zielgenau in
diesem Jahr zu entlasten haben wir heute
früh zum Beispiel die kalte Progression
erst ab 2023 beschlossen hätte man auch
schon 2022 machen können und zweitens
sie müssen glaube ich mit der Wirtschaft
und nicht gegen die Wirtschaft arbeiten
sie Schaden mit ihrem Gedankenspiel der
Substanz der deutschen Wirtschaft sie
legen die Axt an an den Mittelständler
sie legen die Axt an an den Handwerker
sie legen die Axt an an den
Industriebetrieb und unserem Land mit
diesen politischen Meinungen sagen sie
deutlich was sie wollen und das wird die
Menschen in unserem Land nicht dazu
animieren eben hier zu investieren und
deswegen Gott sei Dank letzt der Satz
braucht es hier eine Mehrheit im
Deutschen Bundestag ich bin der FDP Dank
dass sie zumindest in dem Thema hier auf
jeden Fall derzeit noch steht herzlichen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Bremen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nächster Redner ist überlege Stefan
Schmidt Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen mehr
als ein Drittel des Vermögens in
Deutschland ist beim reichsten einem
Prozent konzentriert je mehr Geld ein
Mensch hat desto schneller wächst auch
sein Vermögen und Erbschaften
zementieren diese Ungleichheit
gleichzeitig steigen wir allerdings auch
gerade in der größten Krise seit Ende
des Zweiten Weltkrieges eine
galoppierende Inflation und dramatisch
hohe Energiepreise bringen viele
Menschen an den Rand ihrer
wirtschaftlichen Überlebensfähigkeit wir
in der Koalition Steuern dagegen wir
haben milliardenschwere
entlastungspakete geschnürt haben
milliardenschwere Sondervermögen
beschlossen Frauke Heiligenstadt hat
einige der Beschlüsse entsprechend
aufgeführt wir in der Koalition bringen
die Menschen durch diese Krisenzeit die
Putin mit seinem völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
verursacht hat
und trotzdem müssen wir uns der Frage
stellen wer soll das alles bezahlen ich
finde da muss auch die Frage erlaubt
sein und ich blicke Richtung FDP Herr
Brem muss auch ein bisschen aufpassen
warum nicht diejenigen denen es nicht
weh tut diese Frage muss erlaubt sein
die Forderung Multimillionäre und
Milliardäre stärker zur Finanzierung der
Krisenkosten heranzuziehen die hat ihre
Berechtigung starke Schultern sollten
mehr Lasten tragen als schwache gerade
in der größten Krise nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg davon waren und davon sind wir
Grüne überzeugt
es geht jetzt
es geht jetzt darum die Krise
solidarisch zu bewältigen auch die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben erst gestern in
ihrem aktuellen Jahresgutachten
empfohlen sie haben eine zeitlich
befristet hören Spitzensteuersatz ein
energiesoli als Instrumente benannt
Ideen gibt es viele wie wir diese
Krisenkosten gerecht und solidarisch
finanzieren können was aber das
geeignetste Instrument ist das müssen
und werden wir in der Koalition noch
ausführliche diskutieren und ja noch
sehr dicke Bretter bohren müssen
gleichzeitig sind wir in der Koalition
schon erste wichtige Schritte gegangen
damit sich starke Schultern eben
solidarisch daran beteiligen die Krise
zu bewältigen wir schöpfen die
zufallsgewinne von Energieunternehmen ab
damit stellen wir sicher dass die
Unternehmen in der Verantwortung in die
Verantwortung genommen werden statt
Profit aus der Krise zu schlagen und wir
werden den Kampf gegen Steuerflucht und
Steuerhinterziehung konsequent führen
damit die zig Milliarden Euro
Steuergelder da landen wo sie hingehören
im Fiskus in den öffentlichen Haushalten
im Eigentum aller Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ich finde es gut dass wir heute über der
Vermögensabgabe als mögliches Instrument
für die gerechte Finanzierung der
Krisenkosten sprechen trotzdem werden
wir den Antrag der Linken ablehnen zwar
nicht nur deshalb weil die Koalition
noch über das richtige Instrument
diskutieren muss sondern auch weil die
Linke ist mal wieder versäumt über die
Ursache der Energiekrise zu sprechen den
völkerrechtswidrigen aggressiven
Angriffskrieg Putins gegen die Ukraine
der diese Krise verursacht hat vielen
Dank meine Damen und Herren
also es finden sich trotzdem genug
Argumente für Stefan Schmidt hier von
den Grünen warum die Grünen
diesen Antrag der Linken ablehnen wird
nächster Redner für die afd-
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kollegen als gelernterte die
Hamburger habe ich natürlich ein
besonderes Verhältnis zur Linken ihre
vorgängerpartei die SED steht ja in
erster Linie für Unterdrückung
Einschränkungen persönlicher Freiheit
statt Sicherheit und natürlich auch
mauertoter aber ich sehe das auch
durchaus differenziert nicht alle zwei
Millionen Mitglieder der SED waren
Kommunisten Mauerschützen und
Stasi-Mitarbeiter es gab damals wie
heute auch vernünftige Mitglieder und
kommunalen Bereich habe ich auch mit
vielen einem sehr gutes Verhältnis auch
wenn ich den Ausführungen im
Finanzausschuss Lauscher sehe ich sehr
viel Übereinstimmung mit unserem
Positionen man konnte zum Schluss dass
die Linke nach 30 Jahren in der
Bundesrepublik tut ihnen das leid tut
aber mir nicht das heißt ja in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland angekommen
ist und dann kommen Sie hier Görges so
einen antragsvermögensabgabe
und können das ja positiv betrachten die
Vermögensabgabe ist ja nur Geld aber sie
würden ja gerne die ganzen reichen
abschaffen vor zwei Jahren haben sie auf
einer strategiekonferenz in Kassel
verkündet man müsste die greifen
einfacher schießen ja das ist
nachweisbar und die damalige
vorsitzender richlinger ist heute nicht
da hat dem widersprochen nicht
widersprochen sondern lediglich
festgestellt das was ich erreichen sie
ins Arbeitslager zu stecken
da könnte man ja denken naja die Linken
die in 30 Leuten können also einfach
sowieso nicht durchbringen der wollte so
abgelehnt vor zwei Umstände lassen mich
doch aufhorchen sah staunlich dass
solche Landtag hier hingeschmiert auf
eine Seite 68 Minuten Redezeit bekommt
und zweitens nicht ganz unbedeutende
Politiker der Ampel fordern ja ebenfalls
eine Vermögensabgabe sie Frau
Göring-Eckardt für bundestagsv
Vizepräsidentin die ja sogar ein
Gutachtenauftrag gegeben hat um die
Rechtmäßigkeit der vergnungsabgabe zu
prüfen auch wenn sie es Gutachten
wahrscheinlich nicht das gewünschte
Ergebnis lieferte zeigt sie doch die
würdengedanken inzwischen der ampelfest
verankert sind noch die SPD hat die Idee
der Vermögensabgabe aufgegriffen fordert
Ebensee über die Linken für
Multimillionäre und Milliardäre was die
linkes grünen Weltverbesserer der gern
vergessen
erwähnt ja schon Millionär ist wenn man
schon ein Haus in München oder ein Haus
in Berlin hat oder ein mittelständischen
Betrieb das sind auch schon Millionäre
es gibt die Leute Statistik ungefähr
zwei Millionen Millionäre in Deutschland
wollen sie die alle da schießen oder
Vermögensabgabe erheben und wenn sie auf
die Liste der Reichen sogenannten
reichen Szenen und werden sie ganz viele
Unternehmer dort finden und dann sage
ich ihnen nicht alle diejenigen sind
berechtigt vermögensarbeit zu bezahlen
man hört es denn auf das hängt bei dem
Millionären an es fängt bei den
kaiserlichen es geht weiter zu
denjenigen die einen Sparvermögen
angesammelt haben alle die sollen dann
irgendwann mal Vermögensabgabe angezogen
werden ich sage Ihnen eins der
bezugsdruck keine ledig auch ab sie
können von mir aus noch so viel Waffen
den du keine liefern sie können auch 500
Millionen dort überweisen aber wir leben
uns ab die Bürger in Deutschland mit
einer Vermögensabgabe zu belasten vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege stöber
das Wort hat nur meine Kollege Frank
Müller Rosentritt FDP-Fraktion
ja meine Damen und Herren Präsident nach
den Reden von Tim Klüssendorf und Stefan
Schmidt von den Grünen kann ich den
Handwerkern Unternehmen unserem Land nur
zurufen was für ein Glück haben Sie dass
die FDP dieser Bundesregierung anhört
und wir reden und wir reden auch nicht
über den Weg dahin sondern wir haben
schon eine Einigkeit darüber gesprochen
dass dieser das ist dahin kein Weg gibt
gemeinsame konditionsvertrag ist aber
Übersicht auch alle Diskussionen darüber
damit an dem ich möchte Ihnen mit
Erlaubnis des Präsidenten eine
Fotoaufnahme zeigen diese Fotoaufnahme
zeigt die Altstadt von Görlitz aus dem
Jahre 1989 auf diesem Bild können Sie
live und mit ganz wenig Farbe sehen wozu
linke Realpolitik führt die SED als
vorgängerpartei der BDS und der heutigen
linken hat den 40 Jahren real existieren
Sozialismus auf den Gebieter eben auf
dem ehemaligen zeigt wozu Volks Eigentum
statt eines Volkes von Eigentümern
geführt wird nämlich ausschließlich zu
Verfall überall Verfall wo man
hinschaute nun zeige ich Ihnen ein Bild
von Görlitz aus dem Jahr 2022 gleiches
Bild live und mit extrem viel Farbe und
sie sehen du wohin Eigentum
Eigenverantwortung steuerliche Anreize
und das Vertrauen in die Regierenden in
die Fähigkeit des Einzelnen führen
nämlich zu Wohlstand Wachstum und
Vermögen
eigentlich wäre an dieser Stelle alles
wirklich aber alles über die Fähigkeiten
oder besser über die Unfähigkeiten der
Linkspartei und deren Träumereien von
Sozialismus gesagt doch es gebietet
einfach da Anstand und Respekt vor
parlamentarischen Demokratien auch auf
ihrer ein Anträge einzugehen auch in
umgedreht dieser Respekt vor dem
Rechtsstaat und parlamentarischen
Demokratie bei einigen Partei genossen
nicht oder gelinde gesagt nicht
ausschließlich immer gleichermaßen
ausgeprägt ist wir Liberale Glauben alte
salle Marktwirtschaft an die Werte von
Eigentum und Verantwortung und Vertrauen
stets in die Fähigkeit des Einzelnen
denn ein Wesensmerkmal von
Marktwirtschaft ist die Tatsache dass
ich Leistung eben auch lohnen muss denn
das liberale aufstiegsversprechen dass
du im Leben alles erreichen kannst egal
wo du herkommst deine Hautfarbe deine
Religion darf nicht durch marxistische
Ideen der Linken gefährdet werden indem
in einem über Jahre und Generationen
durch Leistung geschaffener Wohlstand
der Staat einfach wieder weggenommen
wird meine Damen und Herren
die Ideen von Enteignung und eine
Vermögensabgabe ist nichts
anderes Gedanken brutal mit der
Abrissbirne mehr noch eine einmalige
Vermögensabgabe würde und Herr Bremen
als auch schon zitiert mit der Erlaubnis
des Präsidenten des wissenschaftlichen
Beirates des Bundesministers Finanzen
erhebliche wirtschaftliche Schäden
verursachen weil sie das Vertrauen von
sparen und Investoren erschüttert und
weiter Deutschlands über Jahrzehnte
erarbeitete Ruf als sicherer
Investitionsstandort werdet euch eine
einmalige lastenabgabe unnötig schnell
und dauerhaft zerstört und gleichzeitig
man dann meine Damen und Herren ist auch
ihre Annahme Herr Görge die heutige
Situation in Deutschland wird der
Situation nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg zu
vergleichen wo hunderte Städte in Schutt
und Asche liegen das ist doch absurd
völlig absurd was sie hier von sich
geben hier gleiten und
während ihr während die Menschen in
ihrem System ständig Angst haben müssen
dass der Staat ihnen ihr hart arbeitet
das Vermögen wegnehmen will vertrauen
wir Liberale in eigentumsgarantien und
im Gegensatz zu ihnen wollen wir eben
ein Volk von Eigentümern und kein
Volkseigentum und auch der Unternehmer
ist nicht mehr für sie und wie einige
linke Freude und ich war echt
erschüttert heute von einigen Reaktion
von einigen reden hier aus SPD und
Grünen ist eben für uns nicht eine Kuh
die man unterprägt ununterbrechend
melden kann sondern für uns ist der
Unternehmer das Pferd das diesen ganzen
Kacheln in diesem Land sieht man aber
dran und schon heute fordern auch heute
fordern wieder von Leistungsträgern und
Vermögen in unserer Gesellschaft über
paar professional viel im Vergleich von
allen anderen zehn Prozent der
Vermögenden Finanzierung 55 Prozent und
25 Prozent der Vermögen sind
verursachen 80% unserer 300 Milliarden
Einnahmen diesen Leistungsträger sollte
man nicht weiter belasten danke sagen
deshalb leben wir in den Antrag
entschieden ab es ist kein Platz für
Steuererhöhungen danke
Frank Müller Rosentritt für die FDP war
das und auch bei seinem Beitrag noch mal
deutlich geworden auch innerhalb der
Ampelkoalition gibt es darüber keine
Einigkeit nicht nur in Richtung der
Linken so für die SPD hören wir jetzt
Melanie wickling sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich bedanke mich für den Antrag der
einen meinen Augen wirklich wichtige
Diskussion über Gerechtigkeit und
Ungleichheit anstößt kaum ein Land in
Europa hat eine so hohe Ungleichheit bei
privaten Vermögen wie Deutschland und
das ist heute im dritten Krisenjahr in
Folge nicht anders viele Menschen fragen
sich wie Sie über die Runden kommen ich
möchte aber noch eine andere Perspektive
hier in die Debatte heute einbringen
auch in dem Kommunen die eine zentrale
Rolle in der Daseinsvorsorge spielen ist
das Geld knapp zu den Löchern in den
Kassen kommen die erwarteten hohen
Energiepreise zu Hause mache ich
Kommunalpolitik in meiner Heimat in
Ginsheim-Gustavsburg
weiß Groß-Gerau und überall anders
fragen wir uns gerade halten wir jetzt
das Bürgerhaus oder doch lieber die
Turnhalle stecken wir das Geld und das
kommunale Krankenhaus oder in den
dringend benötigten Kitaplatz es fehlt
das Geld an allen Ecken und Enden doch
es gibt auch Menschen die ihr Vermögen
trotz aller Krisen vermehren und das
betrifft in erster Linie die reichsten
in diesem Land allein ein gesundes
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden sagt uns doch
dass sie ihren Beitrag zur Finanzierung
unseres gemeinsam
[Applaus]
wenn die aktuellen Krisen die Schere
zwischen Arm und Reich noch größer
werden lassen dann ist es unsere Aufgabe
dem entgegenzuwirken für mich konkret
bedeutet es wir können über eine Art der
Vermögensabgabe reden oder auch über
eine fairere Erbschaftssteuer die vor
allem bei der Frage der
Chancengleichheit entscheidend ist
wir brauchen jedenfalls ein gerechteres
Steuersystem und das heißt auch wir
müssen die finanziellen Möglichkeiten
der Kommunen in dieser breiten Debatte
im Blick behalten
die Kommunen sind es Fundament unseres
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenlebens sie
tragen eine große Verantwortung für die
Versorgung der Menschen von der
Geburtsklinik über Kitas Schulen
Büchereien bis hin zu Rettungsdiensten
und Altersheimen von der
Energieerzeugung über Sparkassen ÖPNV
bis hin zur Müllentsorgung kurz gefasst
in den Kommunen wird konkrete
Daseinsvorsorge betrieben und ein
Großteil der öffentlichen Investitionen
getätigt doch die aktuellen Krisen
lassen kaum finanziellen Spielraum viel
mehr stehen einzelne Bereiche in
Konkurrenz zueinander doch wer will denn
die Entscheidung treffen was ein
wichtiger ist Turnhalle oder Schwimmbad
Radweg oder Bus Kita oder Altersheim es
geht hier schlichtweg um die
Finanzierung unseres Gemeinwohls in den
letzten Jahren wurden verschiedene
Mittel- und Wege in Betracht gezogen und
mit den kommunalen Haushaltsproblemen
umzugehen Übernahme von Altschulden
durch den Bund Reformen der
gemeinschaftssteuern oder das
Finanzausgleichs verschiedene
länderspezifische Initiativen wie zum
die hessenkasse ich denke dass wir
weiterhin diese Projekte vorantreiben
und uns um eine nachhaltige und gerechte
Lösung für unsere Kommunalfinanzen
bemühen müssen
ich denke aber auch dass eine
Vermögensabgabe ihren Beitrag zu mehr
Gerechtigkeit in der gesamtstaatlichen
Finanzpolitik leisten kann
die grundsätzlichen Argumente für eine
Vermögensabgabe liegen auf der Hand laut
axam konnten allein die reichsten zehn
Personen in Deutschland ihre Vermögen
während der Pandemie im 78% steigern von
125 auf 223 Milliarden Euro gleichzeitig
erreichte die Armutsquote mit 16 Prozent
also circa 13 Millionen Menschen ein
Höchststand ich persönlich finde das ist
nicht gerecht und nur schwer auszuhalten
natürlich gibt es viele technische
Fragen zur genauen Ausgestaltung die
vorab zu klären sind außerdem liegen
schon zahlreiche Vorschläge aus
unterschiedlichen Quellen vor die
aufgegriffen werden können die
Wirtschaftsweisen die sind jetzt auch
nicht wirklich für ihre revolutionäre
Art bekannt empfehlen aber jetzt
trotzdem eine zeitlich befristete
Erhöhung des Spitzensteuersatzes bzw ein
energie-zuschlag für besser verdienende
es gibt zahlreiche Argumente für eine
gerechtere Ausrichtung unserer
Steuerpolitik ich bin gerne bereit über
den Nutzen einer klug durchdachten
Vermögensabgabe zu reden es geht
letztlich auch darum gut durch die Krise
zu kommen und dabei müssen wir die
Kommunen unbedingt mitnehmen diese in
große Maße für unsere Daseinsvorsorge
verantwortlich sind und damit auch für
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt ohne
sie geht es nicht vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
[Applaus]
als nächster erinnert das Wort der
Kollege Fritz künstlerfraktion
mit jedem Finanzausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben ja
schon mehrfach gehört dass über solchen
Antrag der Linken auch schon mehrfach
debattiert worden ist und ich habe mir
das Vergnügen gegönnt die Debatten dazu
anzuhören anzusehen und die Protokolle
durchzulesen und ich kann Ihnen sagen
viel Neues ist eigentlich nicht gekommen
aber wir merkenswert fand ich heute
schon dass die Linke Konrad Adenauer
zitiert und die FDP Karl Marx das hatten
wir bis jetzt in der Debatte noch nicht
aber ganz ernsthaft die Argumente liegen
ja alle auf den Fisch und es ist noch
mal verstärkt worden durch das Gutachten
des wissenschaftlichen Beirats beim
Bundesfinanzministerium das im letzten
Mai vorgelegt wurde übrigens der
wissenschaftliche Beirat des jetzigen
Bundeskanzlers Olaf Scholz der damals
noch Bundesfinanzminister war und dieser
Beirat kommt zu dem klaren Ergebnis dass
eine Vermögensabgabe wirtschaftlich
unsinnig wäre und verfassungsrechtlich
höchst zweifelhaft wäre von daher wäre
es nicht sinnvoll dieses weiter subwo
verfolgen sondern sich um andere Dinge
zu kümmern meine Damen und Herren
und in diesem Gutachten des Beirates
werden verschiedene Argumente aufgeführt
und ich finde ein Argument dabei sehr
wichtig das ist Vertrauen Vertrauen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Unternehmen
in den Rechtsstaat Vertrauen in
Rechtssicherheit und Regelbindung des
Staates und wenn jetzt ad hoc auf das
Vermögen zugegriffen wird es
letztendlich enteignet wird wird dieses
Vertrauen verloren gehen und wir werden
als investitionsstandard Deutschland
leiden darunter und darum sollten wir so
eine Vermögensabgabe gar nicht erst
denken meine Damen und Herren diese
Vermögensabgabe wäre der absolute
standortkiller und von daher sollte man
davon abgehen und ein wenig vermessen
finde ich es auch wo ich den Kollegen
görklicher schätze dass er Herrn
Adenauer zitiert diesen Lastenausgleich
aus den 50er Jahren hinzuzuziehen
und es war eben eine andere Krise und
wir müssten mal gucken und dann sollten
uns einmal bewusst werden in welchem
Zustand unser Land damals war acht
Millionen Flüchtlingen in unserem Land
40 Millionen Wohnungssuche also ich will
ja nicht kleinreden dass wir auch eine
Herausforderung derzeit haben aber die
jetzige Krise die jetzige Situation mit
der Krise nach dem Krieg zu vergleichen
halte ich fast für unanständig meine
Damen und Herren und wir müssen auch
wissen damals hat man es auch gemacht
nicht weil sie umverteilen so wie sie
umverteilen wollen sondern weil der
Staat nicht mehr kreditwürdig war es gab
keine Kapitalmärkte die Deutschland nur
einen Euro oder einen Cent oder einen
Pfennig damals gegeben hätten und
steuerlich war auch nichts mehr möglich
die Einkommensteuer das wird die Linke
Freunde damals einen Spitzensteuersatz
von 95 Prozent das fordert nicht einmal
die Linke hier im Bundestag aber das
hatten wir 95%, also von daher haben wir
eine völlig andere Situation unser Land
ist nach wie vor höchst kreditwürdig wir
sind an den Kapitalmärkten gerne gesehen
wir finden Geld und wir bekommen auch
genug Geld und ist auch schon darauf
hingewiesen worden dass der Staat ja
auch hohe Einnahmen hat natürlich muss
man das inflationsbereinigt teilweise
sehen
2012 also vor zehn Jahren hatten
bundländer und Kommunen ca 600
Milliarden Steuereinnahmen in diesem
Jahr zehn Jahre später werden wir fast
900 Milliarden Steuereinnahmen sind 50
Prozent mehr und nach der
jüngsvorliegenden Steuerschätzung werden
wir im Jahre 2028 eine Billion Euro
Steuereinnahmen haben also wir haben
genug Geld muss man mit dem Geld
vernünftig umgehen und da hat die Ampel
noch einiges zu tun
und das Instrument einer einmaligen
Vermögensabgabe ist kein Instrument
jedenfalls nicht im Grundgesetz zu
angelegt um Umverteilung zu betreiben
und hier wird immer der Eindruck erweckt
die breiten Schultern wie sie genannt
werden würden nicht beitragen ich will
die nur sagen dass zehn Prozent der
Steuerpflichtigen 50 Prozent des
Steueraufkommens der Einkommensteuer
gewährleisten 50 Prozent fast das
komplette Volumen 94% des Aufkommens wir
haben ein linearprogressiven Tarif dazu
stehen wir auch also die breiten
Schultern leisten schon erheblich mehr
und das ist auch gut so das soll auch so
sein aber man muss eben vorsichtig sein
dass man das Rad nicht überdreht und zu
einer erdrosselung kommt die gesund die
grundgesetzlich sowieso nicht zulässig
Wert substanzsteuern haben grundsätzlich
ja das Problem
dass sie unter Umständen auch aus der
Substanz bezahlt werden müssen darum ist
es richtig Erträge aus der Substanz
vernünftig zu besteuern aber die
Substanz selber nicht zu besteuern und
hier wird auch der Vermögensbegriff nie
richtig definiert hier wird immer
Eindruck erweckt dass es alles
Liquidität das hat der Unternehmer oder
wer auch immer auf dem Konto liegen bei
den von Ihnen erwähnten ein Prozent der
Multimillionäre
sind über 60 Prozent in Betriebsvermögen
gebunden das ist das ist gebundenes
Kapital das steht ihnen gar nicht zur
Verfügung und wenn sie sich mal
Familienunternehmen ansehen die ja das
Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft darstellen
die haben meist Gesellschaftsverträge
dass sie gar nichts entnehmen können
dass sie gar nicht frei veräußern können
also dieses alles würden sie kaputt
machen weil diese aus der Reserve wenn
sie denn überhaupt nach diesen krisener
Reserven haben Geld nehmen müssen sie
würden vielen Familienunternehmen in
unserem Land den todesstoßversetzt und
deshalb kann man das auch gar nicht
fordert und verfolgen ich will jetzt gar
nicht von dem bürokratischen Kosten
reden also wir haben ja im Rahmen der
Grundsteuer umfassend debattiert wie man
Vermögen ermitteln im Rahmen der
Erbschaftsteuerreform das ist mal nicht
auf Knopfdruck gemacht und jetzt wollen
sie für eine einmalige Abgabe das
gesamte Vermögen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland neu bewerten sonst müssen
sie ja nicht ob sie die Freibeträge
erreichen oder erhöhen werden das ist
ein Wahnsinn das ist ein
Bürokratiemonster was sie da erzeugen
können ein weiterer Grund dies
abzulehnen das kann dieser ganze Antrag
ist letztendlich ein Griff in die
parlamentarische Mottenkiste wieder ein
Feld versucht der Linken sich an den
Unternehmern und an den Menschen die das
zu Vermögen gebracht hat zu bereichern
erstaunlich wie sich dann hier im linken
Block sich schon der große Einheit zeigt
von daher hoffen wir mal dass die FDP in
diesem Punkt der wenigstens stehen
bleibt und wir uns auf die FDP in diesem
Punkt verlassen können herzlichen Dank
sagt Fritz Künstler für die
Unionsfraktion ja und den Hinweis auf
den Lastenausgleich in Westdeutschland
unter dem konservativen Bundeskanzler
Konrad Adenauer im Jahr 1952 den gab es
jetzt doch schon eine mehrmals das
oberste eine Prozent der Bevölkerung
besaß damals rund ein Viertel des
Vermögens deswegen wurde ja auch große
Vermögen eine Abgabe erhoben über 30
Jahre hinweg übrigens jedes Jahr 1,67
Prozent Emilia fest ja jetzt für die
Grünen wichtige Projekte zu finanzieren
und dabei immer wieder an Grenzen stoßen
dann machen Sie hier wirklich ein sehr
charmanten Vorschlag die
billingsfraktionen ich selbst habe erst
in diesem Sommer gemeinsam mit Katrin
Göring-Eckardt etwas ähnliches gefordert
denn wir leben mitten in der multiplen
Krise die Pandemie ist nicht vorbei
unsere weltweiten Klimaziele sind so gut
wie nicht mehr einhaltbar Krieg in
Europa Inflation Armut es ist ein
ständiger Kampf um eine lebenswerte
Zukunft und für sehr viele Menschen geht
es längst auch um die Gegenwart die
polykrise wirkt einen Brennglas sie
verdeutlicht die soziale Schieflage in
diesem Land und reißt letztendlich
zuallererst die vulnerabelsten Gruppen
in tiefe sorgen umso wichtiger ist dass
die Bundesregierung handlungsfähig
bleibt entlasten kann und möglich macht
die Krisen nicht nur zu entschärfen
sondern die Probleme an ihrer Wurzel zu
packen jeden Tag wird deutlicher dass 16
Jahre CDU-Regierung zu einem enormen
Investitionsstau geführt haben das
zeigen etwa eklatante
Finanzierungslücken im Gesundheitswesen
oder die verpasste Energie-
um den ungeschriebenen
Generationenvertrag Einheiten zu können
um den nächsten Generationen noch eine
lebenswerte Zukunft zu hinterlassen
müssen wir die nötigen Geldmittel finden
und unsere Regierung hat bewiesen dass
sie schwere Entscheidungen treffen kann
und den Anbetracht der akuten Krisen in
der Lage ist das parteipolitische
kleinen zu verlassen die Einführung der
zufallsgewinnsteuer zum Beispiel war ein
riesiger Erfolg gerade aus grüner
Perspektive und es ist kein Geheimnis
dass wir uns auch dafür einsetzen die
Schuldenbremse zu reformieren
doch es muss auch klar sein das Schulden
aufnehmen gerade für laufende Kosten
nicht die Dauerlösung sein kann das hier
ist kein entweder oder wir müssen unsere
Einnahmen erhöhen
und
ja starke Schultern können mehr tragen
wer mehr hat der kann mehr geben und
sollte sich auch stärker an den
Krisenkosten beteiligen dafür stehen wir
Grüne ein
wir wollen Belastungen gerechter
verteilen Menschen mit sehr hohen
Vermögen sollen etwas abgeben so steht
es in unserem aktuellen
Parteitagsbeschluss
klar ist aber auch dass wir das
selbstverständlich durch Verhandlungen
gemeinsam mit unseren Koalitionspartner
in lösen müssen wir sind sehr gespannt
auf Ihre Vorschläge zur Problemanalyse
sehr geehrte linksfraktionen
dementsprechend können wir ihrem
heutigen Antrag aber auch nicht
zustimmen man muss aber auch wirklich
ehrlich sagen Sie haben es sich hier mit
einem knapp einseitigen Antrag wirklich
sehr leicht gemacht ich plädiere für
Ablehnung aber für ernsthafte Erwägungen
in Punkte Umverteilung vielen Dank
von den Grünen hatte mit anderen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von ihr aus der
grünen Bundestagsfraktion auch unter
anderem mit Katrin Göring-Eckardt für
den Grünen partei-tag Mitte Oktober eben
einen Antrag vorgelegt für die Grünen
eine verfassungsfeste Vermögensabgabe
sich dafür auszusprechen aber der hat
übrigens so auf dem Parteitag auch keine
Mehrheit gefunden
jetzt für die SPD die Details sehen aber
ich finde das wichtig dass wir uns
Angesicht der aktuellen Situation uns um
das Thema beschäftigen miteinander um
diskutieren denn das Thema ist mehr denn
je wichtig wir haben es gerade mit
multiplen Krisen zu tun mit dem
russischen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
und die damit verbundenen Folgen mit der
Energiekrise mit der Klimakrise und die
vielen verschiedenen Herausforderungen
die uns gerade als Gesellschaft begegnen
und da ich hoffe wir sehen uns hier alle
einig da wollen wir auf der einen Seite
die Menschen die Unternehmen so gut wie
es geht jetzt unterstützen aber auch
zeitgleich alles dafür tun um Innovation
Transformation in Deutschland
voranzutreiben und das ganze hat
natürlich einen Preis dadurch entsteht
ein ziemlich hoher Finanzierungsaufwand
und in der Vergangenheit ist es uns
gelungen als Ampelkoalition hier drei
entlastungspakete auf den Weg zu bringen
meine Vorrednerinnen und Vorredner sind
bereits darauf eingegangen das will ich
nicht mehr tun aber wenn wir
selbstkritisch mit den belastungspaketen
umgehen und Liebe Union das tun wir also
wir als Ampelkoalition befassen uns auch
kritisch mit den Beschlüssen die wir
bereits gefasst haben wenn wir uns diese
entlastungspakete anschauen dann gibt es
zwei Kritikpunkte die immer wiederholt
werden ob das vom IWF ist ob das von den
verschiedenen Ökonomen ist ob das
teilweise auch von der Opposition ist
Kritikpunkt Nummer eins das ist die
Zielgenauigkeit
Kritikpunkt Nummer 2 das ist die Frage
inwiefern geht Fiskalpolitik in eine
Richtung mit der Geldpolitik das sind
zwei Kritikpunkte die wir uns gefallen
lassen müssen und da finde ich dass die
Vorschläge die der
sachverständigenratform ein paar Tagen
bekannt gegeben hat aber auch die Frage
eine einmalige Vermögensabgabe könnten
eine Lösung sein eine Lösung sein um auf
diese zwei Kritikpunkte einzugehen und
ich will das auch erläutern
erstens erstens wenn es darum geht
entlastungspakete auf dem Weg zu bringen
haben das besonders mit
Herausforderungen das ist ein
Instrumenten fehlt das ist ein
Möglichkeiten der Direktzahlung fehlt
deswegen kommt es dazu dass der super
wohnhabende am Ende in energiepauschale
bekommt genauso wie klein und mittlere
Einkommen die darauf eingewiesen sind
und Liebe Union wer sagt dass wir mit
der Ziege Neuigkeit besser werden müssen
dass wir mit der Gießkanne aufhören
müssen muss auch da einverstanden sein
darüber zu reden wie können wir
diejenigen stärker zu Verantwortung
ziehen die mehr Geld im Portemonnaie
haben die mehr Vermögen haben und das
ist die Debatte die ich gerne mit Ihnen
führen würde
und die Frage wie es darum gehen kann
wie es uns gelingen kann Fiskalpolitik
und Geldpolitik aufeinander abzustimmen
heißt ja nicht nur dass wir eine
restriktive Fiskalpolitik fahren müssen
nein ich glaube wir müssen bei
konsumtiven Aufgaben da müssen wir sehr
zielgenau sein aber bei investiven
Aufgaben da lohnt es sich zu investieren
und das ist auch das was diese
Ampelkoalition macht das ist das was die
Bundesregierung macht und wir haben auch
dafür schon bereits Geld dazu Verfügung
gestellt hauptsächlich basieren auf
Sondervermögen basierend auf
Kreditaufnahmen aber das alleine wird
nicht genügen und deswegen ist auch die
Frage und das ist ja nicht nur eine
Frage der Gerechtigkeit wie meine
Vorrednerin erwähnt haben sondern das
ist auch eine Frage von solide
Haushaltsführung also wer sich für eine
solide Finanzpolitik einsetzt muss ich
auch der Frage gefallen lassen wie kann
es uns gelingen dafür zu sorgen dass die
insbesondere in diesen Zeiten der
Steueraufkommen erhöhen und kleinen
Seitenhieb an Teile der FDP und
insbesondere Richtung Union wer glaubt
solide Haushaltspolitik und solide
Finanzpolitik nur geht wenn man die
Steuer senkt der braucht nur nach
Großbritannien zu schauen und zu sehen
was mit quasiquateng Finanzminister
passiert ist und zu sehen was mit Lift
Trust passiert ist solche Pläne die
keinen Tag halten wenn es nur darum geht
Steuern zu senken die werden auch von
den Finanzmärkten nicht akzeptiert
deswegen das ist auch eine Frage von
solide Finanzpolitik ich freue mich dass
ihr diesen Antrag haben wir werden ihn
zwar ablehnen aber lassen Sie uns die
Diskussion weiterführen dankeschön
vielen Dank damit schließe ich die
Aussprache
hier kommt zum Anteil der Fraktion Die
Linke auf Drucksache 4307 mit dem Titel
einmalige Vermögensabgabe für
Multimillionäre und multimillionärinnen
sowie Milliardäre und milliardärinnen
die Fraktion Die Linke hatten
namentliche Abstimmung verlangt die
Abstimmung erfolgt wieder in der
westlobby zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme haben
sie und das ist ja das übliche Verfahren
hier sozusagen in corona-zeiten dass die
namentlichen Abstimmungen nach draußen
in die Lobby verlagert werden und auch
30 Minuten offen gehalten werden damit
nicht alle auf einmal ihre Stimme
abgeben also über diesen Antrag der
Linken wird namentlich abgestimmt aber
die Debatte hat ja schon gezeigt auch
wenn es in den Reihen der Grünen und SPD
Sympathien für eine Vermögensabgabe gibt
wird es natürlich hier keine Zustimmung
geben zum einen wurde der Antrag als
nicht ausreichend bewertet und natürlich
gibt es auch die koalitions-